hello everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is my 120 my take on Joe Torre
out as New York Yankees manager and let
me tell you right now I am completely
blown away by how many people are sad
that Joe Torre is gone and I'm the only
one that realizes what's been going on
here let's start with this this is not
football this is not basketball this is
not salary cap driven this guy has a
hundred million dollars worth of players
better than anybody else out there in
baseball let me tell you another thing
before Joe came to New York nobody liked
this guy they thought it was the worst
hiring in Yankee history as a matter of
fact a lot of people said in New York
and I know he's a great guy and listen
nobody wants to share wine and eat pasta
with Joe Torre more than I do I love it
however let's be honest the guy is he
the manager that led the Yankees from a
300 lead and lost to the Red Sox the
hated hated hated Red Sox - the only
four straight game collapse in playoff
history yes is this a guy who has not
made the World Series in what seven
years what it is it's unbelievable the
guy had an amazing start but for seven
years now this team has been absolutely
positively this point ting and let me
tell you something if in your job you
are disappointing you are going to get
fired what everybody's like but he's
made the playoffs all these years in a
row and what we've won one game what are
we three and 12 in our last 15 playoff
games guys this is a much-needed move
and here's my favorite but he handles
the big egos well it's Joe Torre the
only person in the world that can handle
egos no he's not the only manager that
can handle egos and I'm gonna tell you
right now this is a tremendous situation
for the Yankees and I love how he then
went down and spit on all the Yankee
fans and they're eating the spit they're
swallowing the spit they still love Joe
Torre it's a mess it's a joke this guy
has been a huge disappointment for a
long time